et à moscou il y a déjà eu les premières
conséquences à des sanctions
internationales la bourse dévisse elle a
fermé ses portes la monnaie le rouble a
perdu 40% de sa valeur donc après les
sanctions occidentales vladimir poutine
a dit vouloir se concentrer sur la
réponse économique à y apporter en
recevant notamment lé principaux acteurs
de la finance russe julie d'un goal of
bonjour vous êtes à moscou où en sont
les discussions y at-il eu des annonces
du côté de créer du kremlin en réaction
donc aux sanctions internationales
n'ont pas encore d'annoncé ensuite à
cette réunion tenue à par vladimir
poutine vous l'avez dit c'est une
réunion qui se tient en urgence vannière
petit qui a introduit cette réunion en
accueillant ses interlocuteurs sur ces
grandes tables dont on a l'habitude d'un
plusieurs mètres séparaient le maître du
kremlin de ses interlocuteurs et
notamment du président de la banque
centrale ou encore du premier ministre
pour répondre à l'urgence il a indiqué
des sanctions qui nous sont adressées
par l' empire du mensonge c'est ainsi
qu'il qualifie les européens un peu plus
tôt dans la journée le porte parole du
kremlin dimitri peskov avait annoncé que
en effet les sanctions leur posait
problème que ça changeait radicalement
l'économie russe mais que la russie
serait capable d'y répondre la banque
centrale de son côté a déjà pris des
mesures avec une augmentation historique
de son taux directeur passant de 9 5% à
20% pour garantir l'épargné sur tout et
bien pour éviter que les russes nay dans
les banques pour vider leur compte et
puis d'autre part le ministre des
finances tente et bien de répondre à la
sanction notamment au gel des avoirs de
la banque centrale russe en demandant
aux sociétés exportatrices de revendre
80% de leurs devises étrangères en
achetant du rouble et puis on entend des
voix s'élever des inquiétudes notamment
et bien chez les oligarques russes qui
demande que des solutions soient prises
que la crise économique est très grave
et qui est donc il faut une réponse
rapide et conséquente
julie comment réagit la population pour
moment à ces annonces du côté de
l'occident notamment
alors écoutez il ya vraiment
une société qui est assez coupée en deux
notamment la vieille population la
vieille génération cette génération qui
a connu notamment bien la chute de
l'empiré soviétique les années 90 un des
années noires pour le peuple russes eux
sont assez résignés et puis sont
favorables à cette guerre contre
l'ukraine 1 considérant que c'est
l'ukraine qui a attaqué les citoyens
russes du dôme bassin c'est ainsi que me
disait me parlait un couple de 70 ans ce
matin eux disent que c'est le prix à
payer à cette crise économique pourrait
bien et bien régler cette situation
revanche est bien la génération un peu
plus jeune est inquiètant est inquiète
pour leur avenir notamment plusieurs
couples avec enfants avec lesquels j'ai
pu parler m'ont dit qu'ils avaient peur
pour l'avenir de leurs enfants qu'ils
avaient peur pour l'avenir du pays puis
ce qui inquiète beaucoup ici c'est que
la russie se retrouvent à nouveau
derrière un rideau de fer à nouveau
coupée du monde on voit notamment il ya
une fermeture des lignes aériennes
l'interdiction du survol de la russie de
la part des européens la rétorsion
décidée par les russes avec
l'interdiction de survol pour 36 pays
notamment bien l'union européenne le
canada les etats-unis bref tous les pays
occidentaux qui ont décidé de ces
sanctions donc pas mal d'inquiétudes
dans la population russe même si on ne
peut pas parler de panique par exemple
ici à moscou nous sommes baladés dans
les rues et on ne voit personne pas de
longues files d'attentes devant devant
les guichets de banques personne ne
tente de retirer la plupart de ces
économies en tout cas dans le quartier
où je me trouve je n'ai absolument pas
pu assister à des scènes de panique mais
on verra dans les jours qui viennent
avec l'impact qui sera de plus en plus
fort a notamment on a vu que la monnaie
russe dévissait complètement on verra
dans les jours qui viennent ce qu'il en
est merci beaucoup julie julie ne
galopent en direct depuis moscou a l'air